you
you
okay that's it I hope you guys enjoyed
the tutorial and I will see you guys
next time
okay so okay let you guys enjoy uh see
you guys next time okay that's it I hope
you guys enjoyed this tutorial
okay let's see actually for this part
we're gonna go through probably like two
parts that I would normally do like on
videos and I think okay at least for
this part it's pretty simple I don't
really think we need the sample code for
this one but for the next part I'll link
to the tutorial so you guys don't have
to like write out on the JavaScript
because nobody wants to write JavaScript
so anyway so so first of all it seems
like there's a lot of people
Oh is there an echo going on I have my
sound muted I'm not really sure why the
plugins
okay how about now a deleted system32 or
we all set now
okay
I don't really know why it was echoing I
think it cuz I had desktop audio on but
it's like my audio was muted so I guess
it just doesn't care if the audio is
muted okay I have to go back and listen
to that one okay now as we were saying
so it seems like at least for a lot of
people there was a slight confusion on
what tensorflow dot j s actually is and
like why you would use it over say just
tensorflow with with python so the the
deal with like tensorflow on python is
that in order for someone else to like
run your whatever your application is
that uses it either you have to host all
the processing power that's going to be
required to run your application or you
need your user to be able to run those
so for example before ten I think it was
before tensorflow digests or which was
before that deep learned is you had like
tensorflow
light and that could run on like a
Raspberry Pi or theoretically a phone I
don't really think I ever saw anybody
running it with a phone but you could do
that but the person would need to
install tensorflow
for that to work whereas with tensorflow
at jeaious you can run that in the
browser anybody can run it in the
browser
there's no installs required and it just
happens immediately so the reasons why
you would use tensorflow tjs are a
little different than why you would use
tensorflow and python so like the first
thing is let me pull up an image see if
I can get this copied over
you should be able to see that so these
are like the lips these are the runtimes
of tensorflow Tijs versus just regular
tensorflow and these are just inference
times over like 1 is it echoing again
don't tell me that I'm only gonna
believe Scott if if I see echoes anyway
for a single inference like it's I don't
know like three to four times slower on
tensorflow j/s then just regular
tensorflow
but these are milliseconds so you can
still make even with tensorflow edge is
a 10 millisecond or really 11
millisecond inference with tfj s if your
clients on a 1080 which they probably
aren't they're probably more likely just
on a regular cpu but even then a 56
millisecond inference is really no big
deal as compared to say even like on a
laptop that's still running just a
regular CPU it's not even twice as slow
it's just a little slower on the GPUs
and they do this running off of either
your CPU or WebGL
so and that'll run on your actual GPU if
the client has a GPU good enough to run
it so it's not like you're still gonna
train your models with like if you're
gonna make a big model that's using like
a ton of data you're going to do this on
your client GPUs like you're not gonna
do it in the browser or anything like
that but it's when you actually go to
like run the inference or if you're
gonna do something more like transfer
learning or something like that so so
really to me I think people are going to
be using tensorflow is kind of alongside
tensorflow you're not really going to be
you know replacing one for the other
that doesn't really make make as much
sense to me like you're not gonna train
large models with this except in the
case where with like tensorflow des jsut
could do very large distributed learning
that you really were never going to be
able to do with
just regular tensorflow so you can do
stuff like that also you could do like
distributed just data collection for
example just where you're collecting a
bunch of data from different users and
like with object detection for example a
lot of users might do custom objects or
something like that and before you know
it you've got quite a few objects that
have been customized by user but you've
got you know maybe they're just doing
like five or ten or something but after
a while you've collected I don't know
hundreds of thousands or something like
that so there's a lot of stuff coming in
with tensorflow at jeaious that honestly
i don't think anybody can really predict
where exactly it's gonna go but to me I
think probably
the big thing is just transfer learning
with it so anyways that's a little bit
about ten strategies and in the speeds
and why you might use it the other
interesting thing is like you mean even
just like little stuff like like right
now you know you you run ads to monetize
a website whereas instead of ads you
could you could be training models to do
who knows what whether it's detect
cancer or something like that like you
could be doing so much more productive
types of things so anyways that's that
and what I'm gonna go ahead and do is I
think we're gonna at least start in just
a little sublime text just to give us
the basic HTML stuff that we need and
then otherwise we're just gonna hop into
our browser so I think I lied I'm not
gonna make everybody type out these tags
so let me put a link to this tutorial in
the description I'm banning for anybody
saying there's echoes can you host
Python models yeah so so with tensorflow
Tijs as far as I know there's no real
easy way to do it with like a raw
tensorflow model but people are doing it
with like chaos models so you can so
tense for lot of jazz is it has kind of
like two major layers there's the core
API and then there's the layers API and
the layers API is more of like your high
level where you're just gonna write one
line and it's like basically a function
with parameters and that's one of your
layers so it's very similar to you know
doing something with TF learn or care
for that matter it's almost a direct
translation so anyways here is the link
to the text-based version and all I'm
doing is just copying and pasting that
HTML block so it's just that HTML and
then we just bring in this script here
so this is basically all you're gonna
have to do if you want to use censor
flo-jo so you just need to bring in the
actual script so I'm gonna go ahead and
save that and let me let me pull that up
but if I just kept the screen hidden for
the rest of the tutorial
then I fit this on so at least in chrome
so I've some people were complaining
about when I put up a link to like a
pong a I example people were saying it
didn't work in Firefox I think so if
you're in Firefox and this stuff isn't
working
get Chrome so once you're in Chrome just
press f12 for the console let me see if
I can just do this and we'll just bring
that up
so basically making making models
intense for load is is very very similar
to what you would do in in like Karos
it's pretty much modeled after Kerris so
you're just gonna start with your
constant and that's going to be model
and then I guess cuz I've typed this in
before already knows I want to do TF
dots winchell so this is just your
typical feed-forward neural network now
you can do other stuff there's TF
sequential and then I think the only
other one right now is just TF Top Model
what about Internet Explorer I actually
think it works an edge I'm not sure
about Internet Explorer I think edge and
Internet Explorer are two different
things I'm not positive but yeah so so
once you've got your model basically all
this does is at least I mean you can
write I think it's the same thing in raw
tensorflow where you could write very
general you could say a tensor is just a
tensor or you could say a tensor is a 2d
tensor or a 3d tensor or E or you could
just yet say like tensor and then maybe
give the shape of the tensor so there's
a lot of things that you can do you can
be very general or you can be extremely
explicit and in general if you're
writing raw tensor flow it's probably
best to be as explicit as possible
otherwise you're gonna probably get in
trouble so you could say TF dot model
and then define your model and it would
be all fine but if we're if you're gonna
do a feed-forward model might as well
call it sick
that's what it is so then when you want
to go ahead and add a layer you're just
gonna save model dot add and then you're
gonna add TF layers dot dense and again
there's all kinds of different layers
that we could add dense is just your
regular you know typical layer and then
you're gonna specify how many units it
has well this is our first layer so it
should it's just going to be an input
layer so it would just have one unit
let's say and then you're gonna give the
clips you're gonna give the shape and
shape camelcase now that we're in not
Python and then again this is just a one
by one okay it's just a really a one so
then that's your first layer and for now
we're just going to do a simple
regression so it just has a single layer
to it so then we're gonna say model
dot-com pile and then here you're gonna
put any of the parameters you want to
compile with so with loss we're gonna do
mean squared error and then you'll
specify your optimizer and in that case
we're just going to use stochastic
gradient descent and then you're gonna
have to start with some actual data so
we'll just do X's and Y's so with your
X's you're gonna do TF dot ten sir and
again these are all your options that
you have right now in our case it's
going to be a to D tensor so we're gonna
say for the X's one two three four
whoops what'd I do wrong here oh we
didn't give our shape so with the
explicit tensor to D don't forget to
specify your shape in this case it safe
for four by one okay so I actually I
don't even know what I'm supposed to do
to overcome when you get this here maybe
I'll just cheat and call it something
else someone help me with in the console
where I can't I guess cuz I called it a
constant I just figure
if I hit an error I could just redefine
it I guess not - okay that's so I'm
gonna do it for now so mo me know there
should be some way to go back but I
guess if you hit the air just doesn't
care anyway make sure I'm not off-screen
cool so then we're gonna do constant for
wise is equal to TF dot tensor to D and
then again in this case what I'd like to
do is try to make it something that we
can actually know is it going to I mean
like yes I could have
can I define a variable after I've
defined the constant though because I
can't go up here and edit this like I've
already defined so I don't think I can
get away with that yeah I think Chad is
just too far delayed I've already solved
for the problem I wish I could sit in
the other live version I could set
latency super low so chat caught up
super quick but nope just I can't modify
it so it was a constant I can't do that
anyway so anyway we want to why not some
way to verify whether or not this model
actually works so all we're going to do
is this is going to end up making a
linear just simple linear regression so
what I'm trying to do is we're just
going to multiply by two so we're just
going to say two four six not ninety
eight eight and then again we're gonna
say that's a four by one
so now we have our exes are wise the
next thing that we need to do is just a
model dot fit and then again X is wise
and there's other things that we could
pass in here including like epochs stuff
like that for now we'll just fit oh of
course
X is 2 there we go and what we get back
is is like promise now I'd never really
heard of promises until I started
messing around here basically a promise
is just a thing that may or may not
return something later so it sounds like
asynchronous stuff so yeah anyway it
should it should return pretty darn
quick in this case it's just like a
simple model and I'm not even sure like
I'm guessing maybe this would say
unresolved or something like that while
you're waiting nice guy but anyway
basically immediately says resolved but
when you actually go to write a real
model and like with a real application
or something like that you need to be
you need to wait for the model that fit
to occur before you actually go and use
it you wouldn't want to start using it
just for all other just same thing as
any any synchronous stuff that you might
be doing if you need to wait for it you
need to explicitly wait for it so once
you've done a fit you can do a model dot
predict and again you're gonna do TF
tensor and we're going to predict
against do you have two tensor and in
this case tensor 2d let's predict a 5
we're gonna say that's a 1 by 1 and
you'll see that you you get I don't even
know what you would call this I'm not
sure that we got this right but let's
see at least for sure anytime you do
this you're not gonna get anything back
necessarily it's you have to know
different than really tensor flow in
Python where it's all kind of abstract
you have to bring it out so let's run it
there we go so we can use dot print if
we're in the console that's not really
gonna help us when we're actually
writing the code so instead you're prime
more likely to use data sink
so it's data sync like that and you'll
get your actual output so in this case
it was a 9.0 - not quite what we were
hoping for we were kind of expecting
that to be a 10 so instead what we can
do is we can fit this what's on top of
my screen another screen so instead what
we'll do is we'll go back up to model
fit and we're gonna say epochs 100 so
this time rather than just doing one
epoch we're gonna do 100 and in fact
let's do 10 first 100 might take a
second we'll do 100 that should be
pretty quick I think it's like a
thousand or more might take a while but
anyways will fit ok that's already done
so then we're just going to do the same
prediction again as you can see we're
getting much much closer to 10
eventually this should be totally
solvable just with over your if you're
just making a linear model you're
probably not gonna you're not gonna
really have to worry too much about the
the over fitment in this case since it's
perfectly linear let's try a thousand so
in theory this should be 1,100 total
maybe eleven hundred and ten or no 1,100
once the other one was only one so
anyway we're getting a little closer to
ten eventually we should get like nine
point nine but then we could say for
example model that predict seven that
should be really close to 14 and so on
Oh what notebook is a chrome console
okay
so up to this point that's like just a
really simple example of doing
tensorflow dot j s and the browser just
doing like simple linear regression but
there's so many other things that we
still definitely want to cover so the
next thing we're gonna do is work on
just like a simple web app but first I
do want to bring up the actual docs here
so like I was saying with like the
tensors and the layers there's like
there's just a just a bunch of different
options that you have to do like these
are all your different tensors you've
got
classes transformation they're trying to
get so the model you've got just a
regular TF now model or the sequential
model which is what we're dealing with
right now continue down so then with the
layers we've been using dense but you
can obviously use a whole bunch of other
layers and then even with even though
there's like a drop out layer you can
also add drop out later on so you don't
necessarily have to do it all within one
layer and try think if there's anything
else I really want to bring up here I
don't know if they have their little
tidy they do so it's also not the
greatest on memory if you leave it
running long enough you're just gonna
slowly like exhaust all your all your
memory so you also want to use TF tidy I
may or may not cover actually using it
but you just need to use that once in a
while if it's like a long-running thing
if people are gonna keep using it at
least for everything I've written so far
maybe I'm just bad but I've it
eventually if I leave it running in the
background I forget about it eventually
my like my GPU just crashes so don't
forget to tidy up from time to time ok
so I think what I'll do is I'll stop
here for a moment and if anybody has any
questions specifically up to this point
let me know and then let me get started
on pulling up the next the next part
when it comes to JS coding training as
much better I would hope anybody who's
actually doing a JavaScript pure
tutorials would be better
I like the echo meme now thanks guys
so for the next little bit we will work
pretty much directly in the HTML file I
just think working in that console at
least when you're just trying to make a
basic model like that
I think that's a little simpler than
working in the HTML file running it
working a little more running it and so
on
sorry buddy discord Scott
you
you
you
you
okay so now let me pull up as soon as I
find my mouse there we go
and here is the link to part two what
about TF Jason node what about it
okay so now we are gonna just work
straight out of the N HTML file here we
move this over and basically we're just
gonna start with the same thing pretty
much everything if you're gonna start
using it you just gonna stuff in the
script tag here and then you can start
making use of tensorflow now the other
thing I'm going to be using here is I
just needed something to make some
charts with and I just found chart J s I
don't really know much about chart J s I
just found it I can make charts with it
done so that's what I'm gonna be using
again you don't really even need to
necessarily go there if you're a little
confused about how I'm making the charts
or something you could check out their
documentation but I I personally didn't
find the need to do it and I'm an idiot
with tensor well how many of you with
tensorflow do but mostly with JavaScript
so hopefully everybody can follow along
if you got questions put them in the
chat but anyway so the only other thing
that we need to bring in is gonna be
there so we're just bring in the
charting stuff so the idea here is to
guess the point where like a user can
actually interact with your applications
so so in our case what we're gonna do is
just try to let the user input some data
and then can we fit to that data so in a
lot of applications that you're gonna do
if you're going to be using tensorflow
Tejay yes chances are and you're trying
to do it in the browser chances are
you're you're gonna be doing it for some
sort of interaction you're not really
just going to be they're not gonna open
up a console okay but you could also
like definitely people might like some
things are so useful like for example
just general object detection for
example you might not take any input
other than maybe from the camera of the
user or something like that but you're
not actually gonna try to fit to their
data you're just gonna predict their
data or something like that
anyway so what we're gonna do is between
the body tags we're just gonna take in a
couple of inputs here so input and we're
gonna say type is text ID equals x and
that's it and then we're gonna do the
same thing for y I actually don't know
if type should be text or if we should
change that Excel actually it's not text
really we're trying to input numbers
like I said I'm an idiot so if anybody
has suggestions on these by the way feel
free to post changes to the scripts in I
think you could just paste bin into the
chat otherwise I could put them up on
github or something or you could you
could put like a gist or something like
that anyway we're gonna go ahead and
save that real quickly make sure that's
working how I intended sure is okay so
the other thing let's do X colon there y
: there why did it go in and save it
okay great so we got some beautiful X&Y
input that we can take in from our user
so then what we want to do is we need to
have like some sort of submit button
type equals number let's do it
thanks guys
so now we're gonna do is inputs and put
again type in this case it's gonna be a
button and ID equals a pen so we're
gonna tie in some some some fancy
JavaScript to that ID there and the
value will be submit so like once a user
actually puts in some data into these
inputs they're gonna click a submit
button and be done thank you thank you I
am pretty good great so now we've got a
submit button is Daniel here I didn't
see Daniel here
Daniel's waiting for his JavaScript to
show up this is still this is still my
JavaScript so anyway so then we have
like this the actual chart stuff so
again I did put the link in the chat but
it's kind of disappeared so just in case
at this point again there's the link so
what I'm going to go ahead and do is
just copy this and no reason to write
out these tags so in this case this is
just getting ready for our little chart
it's just a little div that's gonna have
some canvas information and this is all
just where our chart ends up going so
then once we've got a chart we're ready
to start populating that actual chart so
what we want to do is start with some
script tags and again in this case we
just going to need some X's and some Y's
and our goal is to just take whatever
the user inputs to the X's into the Y's
and populate these and then using these
graphic chart so to do that let me see
I'm actually gonna take this chunk here
and then I'll explain the chunk after
that hopefully that'll go right in cool
so whenever someone actually clicks this
ID right that's our submit button we're
gonna run the following function we're
gonna grab the value for x and y and
then we're going to append the value to
- our little arrays here X's and Y's so
then once we've done that the other
thing you don't really have to have this
but I tried to find a way where I can
just automatically update X - so I
didn't have to do it myself because
generally you're gonna do like 1 2 3 4
but maybe you don't want to do that
anyway so this is what I did I don't
know if this is the proper way to do it
but that's what I did so once we've got
that the next thing we want to go ahead
and do is add in our chart so let me
take this might get messy so now this
code is all like chart jeaious stuff
yeah these little things are off
oh is this part of our fun oh I guess
it's not off it's part of our function
[Laughter]
so so in this case all we're gonna try
to do hopefully at this point is is plot
plot the data that the user puts in so
let me refresh this and see okay great
so as you put in some new data it's just
gonna graph that new data for you
welcome to JavaScript 101 everybody I
hope you guys are enjoying the tutorial
so once we have that set up also I
didn't know this was a thing
I'm pretty sure that's just like put in
there bye-bye Chrome I feel like that's
brand new I didn't notice that when I
was doing the development but probably
not anyway once we have all that we want
to actually start creating our model and
doing all that kind of stuff and doing
that pretty pretty much what what we've
already done so in this case I'm just
gonna take this and actually copy from
here so this is the model code that I'm
adding in so we're going basically our
exes stay the same the Y's is what we're
trying to fit to so this is our best fit
and then this is our model all this
stuff is the same this is just me poking
around with the layers no necessarily
great reason to be using those I was
just trying to try different things so
as usual you need to pay attention to
you know how much you so your input
layer itself so if you're gonna do a
purely linear model your layer unit will
be one weight so at least here it
doesn't appear that you really
necessarily need to have an input layer
your input layer just is your data but
then you still want to have the output
layer defined the only thing you have to
watch out for that for some reason
hasn't thrown an error on my end and I
can't figure out why it doesn't throw an
error but so for example we're saying
this is a hundred and twenty eight units
in this layer and the input shape is one
right and then down here you're saying
okay again we have 128 layer in the
input shape is 128 now strangely enough
you you can have the at least
historically which we could try it if I
remember to you know that say something
else and it doesn't throw an error and
I'm not really sure why and it's really
hard to debug it when your models not
really working right and you've got some
sort of error like that so I'm not for
some reason like I said I've been able
to get away with that and not really
notice that something is wrong at least
in the code doesn't throw an error so
once we have done that the next thing
that we need to do is we need to fit the
data and then draw draw the data
basically on a graph
so I think what I'm gonna do now rather
than try to manipulate that live is I'm
just gonna take to the end here and then
explain what we've changed
I think I also must have uh notes here
okay
paste okay so now still the same thing
is going to be happening once you click
the append we run the function we're
gonna go ahead and every time someone
clicks the submit we're gonna add that
one and then now that the graph code is
happening inside the statement after the
fit again this is probably not the ideal
way to do it especially with chart
jeaious shortages has like things like
chart update or something like that like
it has this little update method like
that so I'm pretty sure if all you did
was update the the best fit rather than
redrawing the chart it might do it a
little more optimized a little more
efficiently but I I don't know I don't
know the answer to that I also don't
really care at this stage so anyway
coming in basically what's gonna happen
is whenever they do click the append
button we're just gonna refit to
whatever data they pass and what you
need to do is like in this case we have
this we're using dot then and this is
why like we have to wait for the fitment
to be done so like for example if you
did like 10000 epochs that would take I
don't know like a minute or two minutes
to actually finish so you wouldn't want
to draw your graph before this is
actually done you would never see any
updates so you have to wait and the way
that we're doing that is just with dot
then then we run the function and in
this function we're just asking it to
predict the best fit line and then draw
the graph no different than before and
like I was saying hopefully like this
chunk of code here isn't confusing it's
just a bunch of options but if it is
this is just chart j/s like there's
really nothing nothing fancy going on
here so now let me save that let's see
if we were hitting any issues there's
another little error that I do hit owner
someone can solve it but let me just
draw this graph real quick
so two-for-one usually yeah I'm not
really sure what this is it looks like
some sort of chart.js thing but skip of
undefined it might be happening because
I'm doing this kind of hacky not really
sure fitment anyway so you can continue
appending here but someone tell me why
that happens there I be curious
so anyways every time someone's makes
this a submission this line gets
recalculated and our graph gets updated
and all of that okay so now do we have
any questions up to this point
and does somebody know why I hit this a
thousand times
Oh even more time so it just keeps going
up
yeah that just keeps going up I don't
know what's going on there this
escalated quickly from it this is number
field that here's a machine learning
model yeah I don't think it did though I
mean I like I feel like it's pretty
simple stuff and I would I would think
that the stream would be ultimately very
boring if I was writing out like this
code here especially because I'm not a
JavaScript programmer you don't want to
see me write this out this took about 47
minutes doing it this way would have
taken four and a half hours
to import statements for tart jeaious no
just tfj s and chart dodges
stopped going up though congratulations
on your pregnancy never mind it goes
back up
oh there's a github issue for it okay
Oh Oh it does it does go up when I'm
asking fifty craft I guess it's like is
it for the the tooltip part or something
or what come on
yeah I wonder why that's happening
everything else seems to be working
about right I just really need to get
this over 9000 real quick
done
you'd be amazed if you type all of them
for yeah right so I'm definitely not
seeing any questions on tfj s and to be
honest that's basically all I really
wanted to get through so far so then at
least then the next thing I want to go
over with tents village s is the pong AI
game that we roll so in this case this
is just a model that runs but we're
still kind of working on this one but
you can navigate to Python per minute /
pong AI if you want it to play it at the
moment all it does is run the model that
was trained locally but the goal would
be to then once you start playing the
game with it - I hate the not even
trying the goal would be to use transfer
learning to then have the paddle either
learn to beat you or I'll just learn to
play just like you so you always have a
worthy opponent that's not too good and
also not too too bad but I think I'm
going to save that one for either
tomorrow or next week I don't think I'm
gonna get on tomorrow though occurs with
mixed charts you mean like if has
multiple lines on a charter what
nice best fitted line there bro oh why
isn't it showing my line let's try again
I don't know why that goes off the
screen there where does what did I get
rid of border with one not even sure why
it's going off the screen when I get rid
of that line but it doesn't seem to show
up whenever I bring it up will you trade
stocks in JavaScript
absolutely I'm already trading stocks in
JavaScript yeah Ted's flow Duchess can
use the GPU as long as there's one
available the tensile ojs syntax is not
exactly the same I just wouldn't be
you've got just different naming
conventions going on but then also it's
really more like Karis like it was it
was built on top of Karis or it was kind
of modeled after Karis I guess you might
I don't know maybe with the core oh yeah
identical but chances are if there's
like some function that you know you can
do in tensorflow so at least like when
we were kind of messing around with the
pong example there were a lot of
functions that we didn't know how to do
in JavaScript but I knew they existed
and tensorflow so I was like okay we'll
just use that but then for example there
was there was nothing for random I
didn't know making random and JavaScript
was going to be like - like shuffle I
didn't know shuffling was gonna be as
challenging as it appeared to be in
JavaScript but that was hard what's my
trading strategy buy low sell high it's
it's working out pretty well
so anyway so I think I'll probably cut
it here I strongly suggest you check out
the documentation for tensorflow das
though because like like once you once
you can just make a simple model like
this I mean you could pretty much do
anything it's just a question of what
can you do in JavaScript and that's
that's where the hard part comes in at
least for me but once you've done that
the other thing that you can do is you
can still you can save you can load
models the only challenging thing with
loading models is it needs to I guess be
on the same on the same domain
I guess as wherever you're hosting your
little JavaScript app something like
that I'm not really sure why why you
can't load it elsewhere but maybe
whenever we do that next one someone can
help us with that because there's got to
be a way to load the model not from the
same source need machine learning
self-driving car series from you in
unity or other simulator it feels like
we would just probably do the exact same
thing I'm not really sure why we would
do that
how about beating Google's GoBot now
possibly like you can definitely like
that kind of that's the kind of stuff I
think that you know maybe not being
Google's go but since most of the people
that would train the GoBot would not be
like go experts but you can train models
you know like distributing the actual
training is I think something that's
going to be super valuable with
tensorflow edge is also like we
currently don't really have anything
that distributes inference like we've
never really other than like an
application but that that requires a
very large like central server to do the
inference so that's like do the actual
predictions and stuff like that so like
right now no one's ever really done that
because that's really never been like a
monetarily feasible thing but as long as
you can as long as you can hey Suraj as
long as you can run it like on people's
devices I just think that changes so
much because even just like the chat
BOTS for example that we run it's a lot
of fun but at the same time each
inference even on a pretty large CPU
server takes about like six to twelve
seconds whereas if you could distribute
that on everybody's devices I think that
just makes a huge huge difference
or if you could combine compiled
tensorflow Tijs models so I'm not really
like so with the tensorflow digest model
you can convert it into and out of
tensorflow to js2 like run with Karis
but I'm not sure about anything else but
if you can convert it from Python to
your web assembly you could everybody's
getting trolled by fake Suraj's over
here
is it possible to create object
detection yeah yeah you can there's
already you there's a pretty decently
developed object detection with
tensorflow edge is like that already
exists I can't really show it because
I'm using the webcam but that works so
the the only thing that's kind of a
bummer with Tensei is is like so this
exists I'm pretty sure this is the one
yeah so you can head shoot they had a
demo I must be missing it somewhere oh
yeah here we go here's the live demo I
can't pull it up cuz it's using my
camera right now
but yeah you can you can run this I
wouldn't suggest doing it on your phone
but you can run it on your computer no
problem
so yeah that's well sort of a problem is
it's still pretty slow I'd be curious
what people without like I run it on a
1080 and it's mmm it's okay but then I
tried to do it on my phone and although
that was an older phone I just got a new
phone I wonder how it would work on my
current phone but that's kind of the
bummer is like you know the the test
flow at j/s was kind of marketed as
being something you can run on like
anywhere easily but really it's almost
like the technology is way ahead of the
hardware as has honestly been the case
with deep learning since like the 1940s
but it's here waiting but at least for
me I couldn't run like I couldn't run
this demo on my phone before how many
objects in infinite as many as you
trained I don't know how many are how
many exist in tiny Yolo how many objects
they have but but it definitely like you
can you could train it to detect
whatever you wanted and the whole point
again if sense float at Jes is that
someone could say here's a speaker
here's a speaker here's the speaker boom
use transfer learning and train that and
then you could let people submit that
data back to the main one and then but
now you could start adding that to some
sort of global model
which programming language I suggest
it's whatever programming language you
can make cool stuff in and whichever one
you enjoy working with so I'm gonna look
this up on my phone and see if I can get
someone else someone let me know how it
runs on your computer especially if you
have like not a good GPU tensorflow yes
live demo
how would you handle corruption of data
I mean that's a good question
you would just have to hope that most
people would not send in crummy data you
could also have people like either it's
like if people were using it they can
either say hey this is a good example or
no that's not right that's not the model
and this is still it's not loading the I
can't even get it to load on my phone
tensorflow one scratch yeah no I hope
not I hope not a bit I don't know that
could that could that could come though
I can't imagine it's too far from being
possible damn that model forty Meg yeah
it's not loading for me I can't even get
it to load on my phone it just hangs so
here's a better question can any oh my
gosh it's cent tax can anybody get get
this to load on their phone it should
pop up with like a question if if if you
can if it can use your mic or your
camera rather but mine doesn't even come
up
they've done it already oh is that in
response to scratch is it off there's no
way I gotta look it up scratch
tensorflow
so by the way a tense flood at JSC toros
over so if you want to skedaddle
have at it I see a medium post no wait
wait no this is from scratch no no I got
too excited tensorflow ins is it is it
just a deep as a just deep learning
model in scratch or is it tensorflow and
scratch with scratch deep learning with
scratch I demand a link if that's
possible if you can't I don't know if
people can put links in this chat but if
you can't come to the discord channel
and put a link in I'd love to see it
moto G for I'm trying
oh it just finally came up so I'm on my
s9 let's see allow allow that took like
I don't know five minutes to load the
model that's pretty brutal now I need
something that it can detect I don't
even I'm not really sure what this thing
detects ooh that's my pet actually so
when I did it on my s5 it was pretty
slow
I mean I'm getting about two frames a
second on my my samsung s nine but
that's not bad it didn't run on my other
phone but it actually runs on the phone
now that's pretty impressive actually
and I know you can play there's a couple
other things on if I go to tents or
float okay yes
oops I'm not actually gonna run it oops
that's not what I wanted to do
where are the demos there's like the one
with with let's see getting started
there's the one with like pac-man and
stuff that one was pretty cool is this
gonna be a series it'll at least be one
more live stream and probably I don't
know five videos or something like that
get an iPhone no never so here's the
issue I have with iPhone although
Samsung is really the same so with the
s5 was my previous phone all I had to do
is like pop off I'm not gonna run it
runs it I didn't think it was gonna be
pop I'm not sure what you're talking
about I mean I don't think it was gonna
be possible on the phone but I just left
it up and it finally came up so with the
s5 right you can pop out like your your
battery and just replace it on an iPhone
you have to make an appointment to go to
the store just for them to diagnose your
phone as having battery issues and then
you need to make another appointment to
go back to the store to get it replaced
and really it results in you having to
go to the store like three times because
you got to go to this store make an
appointment to go to the store drop off
your phone and then come back to the
store again just for a battery it's
absurd oh and you pay $100 oh here's the
demo let's go to the front page and
scroll down so if you haven't done these
these are actually pretty cool the
pac-man ones pretty cool I don't haven't
even done the teachable machine pose
nets alright although maybe other people
will find them more interesting than me
don't touch the battery on a Samsung
device on the older ones it was super
simple just pull it out just pop off the
back now the new ones you have to stick
them on a hot plate
whay and pry them apart but at least on
the samsung device you can still do that
whereas like on the Apple phones you're
gonna probably break one of those cables
when you when you pull it apart it's as
if it was built to be I do have
unresolved issues with Apple it's got is
the one time I try to replace an Apple
phone's battery
I like opened it up and there's that
like cable like right there on the side
it's like built that if you're using
something that like pry open the phone
you're gonna hit it and from then on
I've hated Apple I've never owned an
Apple device either though I thought you
said how to obtain Casualty data
is there a good library tool way to
visualize machine learning models tensor
board that's basically it man and that's
like like for example we were trying to
train the pong AI model and there's
really like training it you can train
you can do everything in tensor flow at
Jas
but visualizing the training is just not
a thing and tensor flow unless I'm
mistaken it's totally might be but the
model just wasn't working couldn't
figure out why so what I ended up
actually doing is taking a bunch of
training data training it in Karis
visualizing that and tents our board to
get the model that I actually just
create the model that I wanted and then
export it that model and then use that
in tensor flow Tijs I think that's
probably the the way that most people
are going to wind up using tensor flow
at j/s which is why in the beginning
it's never it's not really a tensor flow
in Python versus a tensor flow j/s it's
you're going to be using both of them
especially if you're training large
models you're just not going to train a
large model and tensor flow AJ yes
unless you're like distributing it or
you're making custom models for
everybody but again that's kind of the
beauty of tensor flow at j/s is
everybody can have their own customized
machine learning algorithm that's
catered just to them and historically in
order to do something like that you just
you couldn't do that you just couldn't
have something like that as part of your
business model whoa another syntax in
the chat what are the odds what are the
odds
anyway um yeah I think that's it what's
epoch iteration through data like your
training data one full pass to be honest
I have not seen
I've not seen like super impressive
tensorflow J s use cases yet like some
of these are like kind of out there
thinking but at the same time not really
super groundbreaking I'm still waiting
to see someone do something super cool
with tensor flauta j s but I think that
it's gonna change a whole lot of stuff I
think most people are still kind of
thinking of tensor flow at J s as like
tensor flow to another language I don't
think that's it what's next for pong AI
project I don't know if you mean like in
this series or not but what's next is
finding a JavaScript version of pong or
done that copying and pasting that in
taking that data from pong and using
that as training data for a model and
then from there saving the model loading
the model and then also like training
the model off-site because you can train
it Kerris and then you just export it to
it to a format that tensorflow dot j s
understands basically any so username
anything you can do in tensor flow you
can do in terms of loaded is the at
least as of a while ago the the API
coverage was like 90% and now it's I'm
sure it's it's just only grown from
there so anything you can do in I would
probably say anything you can do in care
us you could do in in tensor flow edge
is probably 99% coverage there you don't
have to charge battery on iPhone okay
movie dues speed up your I have no idea
what that is
I'd have to like Google that I'm not
sure what that is
I think that's a typo
NACHA if you want me to create a simple
ml model with tensorflow Tijs just like
go back in the in the live stream we did
that already we created two models
actually
how did the text an untrained image as
an unknown image I mean it doesn't have
it wouldn't have a it's not labeled I'm
not sure what you're asking
you'd have to have another model that
could tell you whether or not it missed
a label or their object isn't actually
there no sponsor button for me why is
that oh you mean that beautiful blue
button underneath the video that most
people could see and you could just
click and sponsor the channel some
people don't have that button I think if
you live in like certain countries or
something
you don't have access because it's I
don't know Google was not feeling like
doing the the money for it I don't know
oh speaking of which with tensorflow @j
s so for example chrome just crashed on
my phone and that's why I was talking
about before eventually if you don't
take great care to clean up your your
your application it's going to crash and
that only took like I don't know 10
minutes to occur on my phone it didn't
take very long at all how do I land a
job at Google
I do good in school or if you do a lot
of searches on Google for like technical
questions eventually you'll get like a I
don't know what to call it a challenge
and then complete that challenge and
then you'll get your interview at least
that's probably the most surefire way to
get do lots of technical searches on
Google
my screen popped out from a growing
battery on an iPhone that's just the old
battery nope I don't live in Texas
anymore sad
what do you do with drums whatever they
say you don't defy them what was your GP
I'm not sure that's a question you asked
people it's an interesting way to phrase
it what is the differences in the link
in projector dot tensorflow
I don't know what is that I may be sure
what that is
projector
new sponsor Daniel cooky Ella welcome
who is your biggest inspiration for ml
stuff I honestly don't have somebody
that I would pick for that why move so
my wife graduated medical school and
started in residency in Alabama so we
had to move planning to go back to Texas
but we'll see
ooh mo Venus I feel like I just googled
that is that the I hate to be wrong is
that the is are you spelling that right
isn't that the mobi mova Dias I think
you're talking about that Mike is it
Mike no it's Intel Tom oh it is I
honestly haven't used one so I couldn't
tell you I will say those I've used a
couple of they're like little compute
sticks there's like Intel compute stick
things those are pretty crazy they they
pack a lot and third they're like on par
with like the those Nvidia like dev kits
I can't think of the name like the Tegra
dev kits and all that stuff I lawang
thank you for your sponsorship they're
they're like better and they're like a
tiny stick I don't know how they're
doing that although I mean it's not as
functional so I think it just like plugs
in by a USB or no I think the one that I
used what had a I think I had like a
HDMI plug on it
that's cute everybody makes sure to talk
to scoot boot there is stuff back page I
think Daniels sponsor just for the scoot
Kappa
so so you can see let's see if it's
still doing it no see it see that lag
that's because it's slowly but surely
about to blow up my GPU probably streams
just gonna cut out randomly but yeah
it's like super messy and it's super
hard to keep that keep that from
happening
oh yeah I was gonna go to projector at
10 sir I don't know what you're talking
about with projector projector can you
put like a link or something oh here we
go embedding projector is this not like
the projector that's in a tensor board
like these are two totally different
things if that's the case like
projectors just for visualization
purposes it's like if you're trying to
figure out like what's going on in a
model or something like that like we use
these for like the word vectors in in
the chat BOTS so you can see like
related words yeah and this extra list
looks like a word vector it's exactly
what this is
anyway so you can see like related words
for example what was my GPA did not the
grace GPA I didn't actually do that
great in school I I wasn't I just never
did homework so if you gave I did good
on tests but if you gave me homework I
just didn't do it I felt like if you're
gonna spend like eight hours at school
when I get to come home it's my time
thank you good sirs and probably the
only reason I did good enough on my SATs
just for automatic acceptance into the
school that I ended up going to not a
fancy school by any means though but
yeah that was it Scott how come how come
the scoot boot isn't working do you own
a TPU I wish I even tried to get them to
just let me use a TPU for a short period
of time and I couldn't mainly 4cv see
I've never used GPU like OpenCV like
CUDA enabled CV so I couldn't really
tell you the person you should ask for
that is that pie image search I'm
blanking on his name but that guy Adrian
I can't think
that's exactly what I think every day
after school yeah especially because
even at school like you do so much
sitting I mean it's been a while since
I've been in like especially like high
school and stuff but you just it's so
boring and the last thing I want to do
is go home and do homework unless I was
interested in the topic but I mean high
school is like this is the most sold
draining thing ever or middle school
apologies to anybody finding themselves
still there where's the guys Twitter
trying to pull it up Adrian
Rose Brock yep that's how you should ask
about your CV build probably a CPU
intensive machine but I'm pretty sure
there's like CUDA enabled OpenCV now so
but I'm not really sure if you can do
that in Python yet or not
Python CUDA TV
all right now I think they're talking
more about that dev kit let's see
hey man as long as you got a 100% on
everything else if it was 30 percent of
the grade no problem as anybody used a
CUDA CUDA CV speak of the devil right
here that's exactly why I tell you that
just ask this guy compiling open CV with
CUDA support so yeah I guess I guess it
would be a GPU machine but like I said
I've never done it I wonder how good
open CV is once you use the GPU the GPU
is only going to shine if you're doing a
lot of like small calculations but a lot
of that a lot of the things that open CV
is doing for you are like these like
stupid little counts so it probably
actually helps a ton
is it possible of a model that goes
forward and backward yeah yes sir
can you load a the pose net no I can't
yeah the thing I like about pie image
search is this he's just like a
marketing genius because basically he
just always has like his write-ups he's
got like full write-ups to and like
really holistic things but he also just
answers your question so you'll like
search like he's got Google search on
like lock with OpenCV like I don't know
who's gonna compete with this guy for
OpenCV but like every time I ever have a
question with OpenCV I just type it in
and I always find this site with like an
exact tutorial for what I need
what's that model then non-sequential
it's just not feed-forward that's all
there's a lot of models that you can go
back on like that it's just called
bi-directional I can't remember now I
don't know if Daniels still in the chat
but I think the chat bot was a
bi-directional we tried so many
different things though so I can't
remember if bi-directional was uh is
where we ended or not
new sponsor LUN ster full thank you for
the sponsorship good sir enjoy your
emotes in your beautiful badge icon at
some point right now
every month is like the same law icon
but at some point we're gonna when it
change those someone was supposed to
work on that along with the GTA trainer
and a whole bunch of other things but
they're off doing who knows what who
knows when
here's the next really important
question when you click on the emoji
thing in the live chat how do you get it
to go away
like it's it's exhausting most wait if I
click oh you click back on the keyboard
got it playing factorial right right
so I'm trying to see if anybody else has
come up every time I search for like
really cool examples of tensorflow @j s
being used it's pretty slim pickins
right now although there is this one
example whoa stock price prediction
using tensor flow the issue with using
deep learning with stocks is that is
just non-stationarity
of that kind of data so that data
changes over time so like trying to fit
time series data like stocks where
fundamental things are changing is
generally an unsuccessful enterprise you
can do certain things with it especially
if you're like trying to calculate like
real value or something like that but I
think a lot of people make statistical
mistakes when they're trying to use like
deep learning or any machine learning to
predict prices computes a factorial
tensorflow a J's is efficient enough
test floridays is extremely efficient
it's like it's like three times slower
right or if you can get someone to run
it on their desktop it could be up to
three times faster per single inference
I showed that picture initially as if I
can phone to it but it's it's definitely
not not slow by any means like it's a
pretty pretty impressive speeds already
and I think eventually the technology
will come to get us to go even faster
but this was from the little tensorflow
dev summit from 2018 when they first
kind of were talking about tensorflow
HJs and these are single inference
speeds on I think it was like em NIST
data or something I can't remember what
exactly on but if if the person has a
like a high end GPU it's like three
times faster to run it on their machine
but with
like on a CPU it's really not even twice
as fast to run it like to just run it on
in tensorflow j/s it's not twice as slow
I guess which is pretty impressive
considering again we're just using WebGL
here so so so that's that's pretty good
and like I said the fact that you no
longer if you want to distribute some
sort of deep learning application you no
longer have to host that model which
it's always a very heavy amount of
hosting that's required like I said with
like the chat bot for example that
Charles chat bot each inference alone
takes about 12 seconds and it's just
it's very slow now you could inference
in in clusters and like batches and
that's a little quicker so again this is
single inference what I'd really like to
see is someone break down like bulk
inference maybe like 5 inferences at
once or something like that but but
again I'm not I'm not sure what the use
case necessarily would be other than for
training
so for fitment purposes I wouldn't mind
seeing train times with like a batch
size that's realistic to what people
tend to use like let's say 32 or you
know something like that
I'm not sure who they is as far as
stealing your model and tensorflow J s
but yeah the model is downloaded locally
so the model gets downloaded to the
person's phone so yeah if you if you
wanted to for whatever reason keep like
your model proprietary you could but in
I mean models I mean yeah if you want to
protect your model you're gonna still
have just no different than anything
really like if you don't want clients
running it you've got to run it on your
server always sent X YouTube really
doesn't like your age I'm not sure why
you're saying that what do you mean did
you talk on the discord he generally
doesn't I don't answer technical
questions on the discord but if you come
into the general chat I definitely talk
there can you make a video for the path
to deep learning honestly I think the
path to deep learning is just I would go
through the this series here I mean like
there's you don't necessarily have to
start the the basic level but so with
machine learning this series runs
through pretty much everything so this
is just machine learning stuff but then
if you wanted you can start at the deep
learning part but the path to deep
learning is going to be different for
everybody there's really no one set path
there's no way you're not gonna learn
deep learning by following someone's
specific path for you like the way
you're gonna learn is by working on
projects or doing your own research
there's no way you're going to get
around trial and error when you're
learning something complex like that
how do you recommend someone learn
programming if they have the logic but
issues with the syntax I just use Google
I mean there's a lot of times I don't
know how to do the syntax but I know
what I'm trying to do I just google it
eventually you either do it enough to
where you remember it or you don't do it
frequently enough to justify storing it
into your memory so who cares but yeah
just google it I guess
learning paths through all of ml I mean
you could try you could try to learn a
bunch of like you know something really
like you you're just not gonna learn all
of ml I think that's like you can learn
general stuff about all of ml but if you
really want to do to have like a strong
understanding of like all the things ml
good luck
I mean people people are dedicating
their lives to like we're like one
specific facet of ml the only practical
uses of ml I see her advert it
advertising or prediction type services
I mean that's basic I mean ml does a lot
of prediction but there's a big
difference between predicting say where
the car should drive versus predicting
what kind of movie you might like right
there's not to me there's not much
social value in necessarily that one
could make the argument but there's not
much social value in like having a
service that predicts you know what
movie you like at a difference between
85 percent accuracy and 95 percent
accuracy but when it comes to like
self-driving cars let's say using like
deep learning for example to you know
get it right 99 percent of the time
that's super important and also has a
lot more social value
show me your desktop wallpaper so well I
can minimize but you'd only see the one
screen so it's a it's like a NASA image
I want to say it's a Andromeda you can
find it it's like host on NASA yeah this
is it
I'll pull it up copy image address it's
a big image probably not recommended to
actually have as your desktop background
let's see how do I get to the so tedious
to get this exact image let's see if I
can pull it up here we go over yeah
there you go
that's my desktop background it's a it's
a good size because so I have four
monitors and this is enough to blow up
cuz I don't have them like one two three
or four like all linearly there's like
one on top one here and then one on each
side how many hours a day or a week do
you spend doing extracurricular studying
for programming non job-related
basically all I do is non job-related
I don't really do that much contracting
consulting work so I don't know a lot
most of my day is just screwing around
with programming I feel like we get this
quit the difference between like AI ml
and deep learning so AI doesn't have to
be machine learning AI could just be
logic based AI is anything that's
artificially intelligent period it could
be a bunch of if statements machine
learning versus deep learning like deep
learning is what you're doing with like
neural networks multi-layer neural
networks machine learning is using a
machine to fit some data ever been to
Clear Lake Texas yes I've been there
I've been pretty much everywhere in the
state of Texas which is big state if you
guys didn't know
Texas is like four times the size of all
of Europe if you look at it on a map
it's wrong because like maps are like
flat and square but if you were to
actually you know draw a map to scale
that's how big Texas is what's your
source of income I'm starving you click
that beautiful blue sponsor button under
the video having considered other
libraries like Theano don't think I'll
do Theon oh it doesn't appear to me that
Theon owes getting anywhere hi torch if
I was gonna do another library it would
be PI torch what's your main interest in
programming at least right now doing
like applications with machine learning
is cool or these like homework questions
what's the Taryn screen test set and
validation set in general your
validation sets probably what's being
run each loop so you're just validating
their wares like your test sets like
totally out of sample your touch like
validation set you're like you're
checking that every iteration
whereas test set is like when you're all
done training you're not gonna train any
further you check your test set you
kidding me on the size I mean I don't
know I'm pretty sure is like 4 it could
be 5 times as large I don't know it's
very very large though Texas is no way
bigger than you know it's like four or
five times the size of Europe it's it's
it's because of the way the maps are
drawn it's just it's absolutely massive
our neural networks ml yeah
where should I start with AI that's no
no it's definitely five times bigger we
got some people trigger to the chat here
I'll find a picture
I'll find a picture for you guys
I'm just not finding the photo I'm
hoping for
so most maps of Texas just like aren't
drawn to scale but here's a proper the
scaled image of Texas that's a satellite
photo so like when you see most maps
they're not like satellite this is this
the real deal
this is like from a plane I think or a
satellite you know the deal I'm gonna
try to find one overlaid over Europe
most of the ones I see are just like
those drawn Maps obviously super
problematic
[Laughter]
man I just cannot find the actual image
I was looking for
I've seen one image that's like just
Texas is like way bigger than Europe but
I just not finding it it's probably been
removed cuz nobody because people get
angry about it apparently you can't
handle the truth
actually it's so the one I showed you is
older it's since been updated this is
the current situation
[Music]
it's not virtually all of Europe I mean
it's it's like seven two tents up to ten
times the size
at Rowland flota j/s actually it's it's
Texas flow Jas you missed the last 20
minutes you didn't miss anything
how'd you integrate Charles AI to twitch
and twitter twitch and twitter api
somebody needs to find me that photo I
used to always be able to Google Image
Search
Texas verse like Europe and it would be
like a gigantic overlay if Texas over
Europe I can't find it it's just
unfortunate
maybe I'll have to photoshop one or
something
it's creative model it shrinks Texas
yeah okay I think we're all we're all
set on the on the tensorflow - yes in
the size of Texas I think we've all
agreed that Texas is much much larger
than Europe anyway if you guys have more
questions you can post them once this
video gets posted up you can you can
leave them below otherwise next week
we'll get into doing the pong AI with
tents float J s both just collecting
that data training that model and like
something like chaos or something like
that Karis is like super simple and then
importing that into tents float J s and
then using that using that with our
model and then possibly in that same
tutorial we can probably get into using
like transfer learning to hopefully get
that model to be a little better
you can't just train it raw based on
like a couple of gameplays you'll never
like you just can't collect enough data
to get a good model unless you're
planning to play it for like ten hours
or something like that so anyways that's
all for now thanks for dropping by
everybody thanks again for the sponsors
Daniel Allen Wang and LUN store for till
next time